hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back I'm for honoring it and
today we have some stuff to talk about
lots of balance updates features news
coming in season 9 and some other stuff
like that so let's get started with
today's video
so first up to get the other stuff out
of the way dance of death is coming back
to the game so if you haven't played
that go check it out and there's also an
event challenge where you can be the
faction with the most amount of
takedowns in dance of death and you'll
get some steel as a reward so that's
gonna be going on this weekend so if you
want to get some extra steel now if we
participate in that next is the weekly
discount and mythic outfits and in
specific the Solaris the dawn sky in the
zodiac warrior mythic outfits the ones
with the weird color behind them -
orange red and the blue one those are
going to be discounted for the week so
if you want to go grab those go get them
while you can they're gonna be 10,000
steel instead of 15,000 the new content
of the week is a rock-paper-scissors
emote you can now play
rock-paper-scissors with your friend or
foe whatever you want to do looks really
sick and the H character has a different
animation for the rock-paper-scissors
when as you see in the gameplay in the
background so I cannot wait to grab this
grab the e mode if you want and the
ending kind of looked like there was a
signature for this I'm not entirely sure
if that was just for the video or there
is actually a signature victory emote
I have no idea I haven't been on for
honor J so I cannot confirm this and the
next thing is balance updates the thing
everybody's been wanting and to
summarize some of the points that
brought up and the most important topics
they're gonna be looking forward to in
2019 or season 9 is gonna be target lock
in reaction reduction and revenge when
not in a gank so target lock in or
target lock out and whatever you want to
call I will explain a little bit more
later in the video as more in depth what
everyone's been in this situation your
3v1
and you want to just get a lock on to
that specific hero maybe it's the Orochi
running away and you want to hit him
really quick to even out the fight but
the game won't let you I'll get into a
little bit of a more helpful tip with
this in a bit but like I said that is
something they're considering in the
future reaction reduction is basically
at the top level of play most moves that
are usually considered openers don't
really open up these top players as
often because obviously there's some of
the best players in the game so this is
a big problem which is why most players
will spam zone cancel since they're
quick like no Bucci zone or PK zone
which I'll say it a lot in 2v2 fights
they're working on to fix this issue so
there is more moves being used at a
competitive level which means more
viability for more other heroes as well
and then revenge when in a gank the
issue is when someone blocks or parries
a lot they get a lot of revenge
even if it's a 1v1 fight they're
currently testing this at the moment one
suggestion mean a couple other people
came up with is that if you're in a 1v1
it your revenge bar only goes halfway up
and as soon as the camera zooms out to
the other person your revenge bar can be
fully accessible and you can actually
get revenge next is hero changes and
shougo key will be getting an
improvement but it kind of seems like
they're hinting at a rework the amount
of times that they're kind of like
winking and stuff like that throughout
the dev stream so I do believe she goki
is going to be getting a rework in
season 9 which is awesome news I believe
this is going to be simply because a
simple change like I said will not be
able to fix this character not a simple
buff to damage or something will fix him
so there's gonna be a lot of tweaks
within that character but we'll have to
wait some time for that and hopefully
towards the end of season 8 and the
beginning of season 9 we'll get a lot
more info on that law bringers also up
next to be getting changes in the future
they didn't hint at a rework for this
character but there definitely will be a
change for him coming in 2019 or in
season 9 like I said no dates specified
or the changes specified they just want
to make sure that he is viable in every
game mode 1/v ones for before stuff like
that so hopefully the change for him
will be really good and then some small
bits of updates PK is gonna be getting a
buff soon as well
like I said no specifics but they did
want to bring her up the tearless inch
they seem that she lacks a little bit
and shinobi and warlord are pretty high
up on the tier list roughly because of
the fact that there are out of guard
moves that being shinobi slide and
warlords crashing charge are gonna be
very are very good moves to use
especially in a 1v1 setting because it
promotes this unlock a meta type of
fighting so they're gonna be probably
nerfing those two moves for those two
characters in season 9 and then also is
the state of balance and that's going to
be coming out next week in for for
season 6 so I believe we get to see that
as well which is gonna be nice I'll
gladly recap that one that releases
hopefully we'll have some good
information about the season 6 date of
balance next are the questions sent by
the community for them to answer it and
to recap it the number one question is
about level 3 bots specifically in the
arcade mode so they plan to tune these
guys down a bit and up a bit depending
on the level so level 2 guys might be
getting a little bit harder to fight
because they're pretty trash and level 3
BOTS will not be able to deflect lights
and parry lights every single time you
throw an attack this specific nerf the
lights in Perry you know all those
lights and getting parried and deflected
be changed in the next patch which
hopefully should be coming next week so
they'll be discussing that next week
which is a really good news and this
will only pertain to the arcade mode for
this type of nerf and then next was one
of shougo keys improvements that they
kind of hinted at was the ability to
faint be heavy unblockable now I could
be totally wrong I haven't pledged to go
get a hot minute so but I swear I
thought you could faint the heavy
unblockable maybe it's not at specific
times anymore but it regardless it is a
very easy move to detect and parry so
that would be changed at a later date
like I said probably during his rework
in season 9 and then lastly gladiator
zone is going to be receiving a change
as well they're gonna be need to give
him some faster combo lights and make
his neutral heavies and skewer viable so
if he does receive a change in the near
future it will be a nerf and a buff
together which is nice and the devs also
acknowledge light spam and more
specifically on console but they said
that at a competitive level light spam
doesn't work as much so they still take
into consideration all of our complaints
but it's not a crazy issue for them at
this current moment and lastly I wanted
to bring to light this one document me
and a ton of other people have been
working on in the background they did
bring it up during the stream and but
basically a for honor arena who is a guy
who of course his name I think he goes
by the name of Raven not to be confused
with the youtuber Raven this is a
completely different Raven he owes the
four honor arena Twitter account he is
the one that composes all the tournament
or most of the tournaments within four
on earth he a bunch of tournament
organizers tournament players and
youtubers including myself have put
together a document showing the devs
what we want changed in our top three
most specific things like immediately
and then we're gonna continue to add to
this list as the days go on so let me
know your thoughts on this document if I
can link it in the description I will
but the top three things that we wanted
mostly was the target lock-on which I
just described a little bit the one
thing that we had an idea for the target
lock-on is when you're locked on you
don't use the sprint button and you
don't use the camera reset button which
is clicking in the left thumbstick and
the right thumbstick for a controller so
we're gonna have the idea is if you lock
on and you want to turn to the left for
the character you click the sprint
button or if you want to go to the right
you click the camera reset button as to
actually choose who you want to pick
instead of leaving it up to chance next
with spectator mode and we thought this
was the most important thing we want
spectator mode to be in the game and
some type of camera movement which will
help a lot with console players and
cinematic movie
with NVIDIA and Zoll being on PC that
every single PC player has access to it
and console players don't have it at all
so that would be a very similar thing to
Nvidia Ansel like a theater mode and as
well as just spectator mode would help
with the competitive scene and well and
kind of make it flourish a little bit
since the competitive scene is a little
bit lacking in this game and the way
it's to spectate is just basically
killing another person and having them
watch the dead teammates and stuff like
that which isn't technically
professional so this is one thing that
we also stated and then lastly we also
wanted every single character in the
game to be competitively viable now we
haven't given specifics yet as to not
overwhelm the devs but later in the
future what we will be discussing
specific changes and giving it to them
so there will be more news on that at a
later date yeah that's all we really
have at the document at the moment like
I said if I can link it in the
description I will as you can see all
the specifics and all the people who
worked on it including myself and tons
of other great great people as well you
guys that's gonna be the end of it
hopefully you guys did enjoy them I know
your thoughts they should go keyword
possibly coming in 2019 or season 9 the
lagering or change of stuff like that
yeah I like the V if you do enjoy
subscriber if you're new I cover the
informational side a foreigner that
being balanced changes hero updates
patch notes leaks all that good stuff
the news of for honor but that guys my
two most recent videos will be on screen
if you guys do want to check that out
when that guys hope ever grace today
thank you for watching the video and
peace out
you
[Music]
you